rolls Harris
Entertainer and convicted sex offender
has apparently died he was 93 this has
been confirmed by a registrar at
maidenhead Town Hall who has confirmed
that Rolf Harris has died now he was a
man an Australian who was an artist
found Fame in the 1960s and later on in
the 70s and 80s as a singer and a TV
presenter as well but then in 2014 he
was convictive and decent assault
against four girls and sent to prison
for five years and nine months there
were charges that he denied but he was
found guilty of those charges his family
standing by him throughout these court
cases it's understood that in recent
years after being released from prison
he was living in Bray in Berkshire that
he was receiving care for neck cancer
according to his family and was
receiving Medical Care at home because
of that but that is the news that has
just broken in the last few minutes that
Entertainer and convicted sex offender
Rolf Harris has died at the age of 93.
now of course his conviction and the
charges that he faced uh came around the
time that Jimmy Savile was also
um disgraced and there were
um a lot of people who made links
between these two gentlemen and the fact
that they worked at a similar time in
the same industry but before that he was
well known and well-loved he took part
in many programs that exploited his uh
artistic abilities
um uh was on television for much of the
60s and 70s in various drawing programs
lots of children's television programs
that he took part in during that time
and was also a singer and had success
with Tommy Kangaroo Down Sport and the
song two little boys as well which also
was very successful in the charts but
all of that of course was thrown into
Shadow by what happened in
2004 when he was convicted of in this
and assault against these four girls the
courts heard that he had used his
position as a celebrity to take
advantage of these children and he was
sent to five years and nine months in
prison he always denied the charges but
the jury found him guilty and he spent
five years and nine months sentence in
prison when he was released he returned
back to his family home
in Bray in Berkshire and we understand
that in recent years he had been
suffering from throat cancer and he had
been receiving treatment at home for
that throat cancer
and the news that has been revealed in
the last few moments and confirmed by
police and confirmed by maidenhead Town
Hall registrar is that at the age of 93
Rolf Harris has died